[Music]
dylan is with us in springfield mass hey
dylan what's up
hey how's it going dave better than i
deserve how can we help sir
uh well i'm 25 i make about 80 grand a
year uh i got 420 bucks a month in
expenses i'm currently debt free minus
my 401k loan that you're just talking
about
um i'm currently living with my
grandmother right now
i got 22 000 in savings and i want to
buy a house but like i'm not real sure
where to go from here and what to do
with the market the way it is and all
the houses around me are pretty
expensive so i'm just not super sure
what to do cool yeah it's a great
question how much is your 401k loan
uh i think there's about eight left on
it okay write a check today and pay it
off
okay
and now we've got not 22 but now we have
14.
but you make 80 and you got no bills
because you live with your grandmother
right so you pile up money pretty fast
can't you
right minus the expenses because i kind
of take care of her too with you know
groceries and everything else but yeah
well what i would encourage you dylan is
to figure out what your expenses are per
month
and then get an emergency fund of three
to six months worth of that have that
just cash in the bank which again that
18 it's gonna it's going to help you're
the 14.
um that's left in your savings will be a
good jump start if not completed
depending on again what your expenses
are um and then from there is what we
call baby step three b
and that is where you're going to save
up for your down payment on your home
and that's you want to save up at least
10 to 20
and then the formula we always use is
that your take home your your payment is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed rate
now that's to say if you want to buy a
home and i don't know your situation uh
are you single
yeah yeah is is buying a home something
you want to do or you do you want to
rent for a little bit do you want to
stay with your grandmother like what are
you what do you want to do
i'd like to buy a house okay i had one
already i sold a year ago gotcha because
of uh
they built houses right on top of mine
so i sold mine but yep i do
want a house yeah yeah yeah so yeah when
you get to that point that you have that
down payment saved up
um i think it's then it's a great time i
mean you're gonna you're in a good
position obviously you're gonna be
completely debt free by this afternoon
because you're gonna write a check and
get that taken care of
uh and you have some good savings you
can save up a little bit more but that
um that down payment savings will be
your next your next step
good work brother good work the question
you got to ask it sounds like more than
anything is just how long do you need to
be there and want to be there
to
take care of your grandmother in this
situation
and um you know
it's working for now
uh is that a three-year plan a
three-month plan five-year plan and then
that'll help you answer when you're
ready to buy but yeah get out of debt
build your emergency fund and save your
down payment like rachel laid out that's
exactly what we teach